all right today I'm going to answer the
question that I get the most often which
is that if I was starting over again
from scratch and I had no money in my
bank account I didn't have any special
skills or network or people that or
audience to to use how would I do it how
would I make myself successful how would
I make my first million if I was
starting over from scratch again I'm 25
years old and it's 2024 what would I do
today and um I'm G to answer this
question I will give you an answer to
this question I'm worked up as you can
see because I got an answer to this
question
[Music]
I want to give you an observation about
this question because the question is
actually I think we would all agree it's
a money question it's a success question
how would you make it that's really what
people want to know but they always add
this if you were 21 years old again if
you were 25 years old again they add
this age component to it which is sort
of funny cuz um I don't care if you're
21 you're 31 you're 41 if you're broke
you're broke if if you're not successful
you're not successful it doesn't matter
what age you are it is your day one you
can't go back in time so really it
doesn't matter what what how old you are
you know the the reason I think people
say if you were 21 again or 25 again is
because they're like if if all the
possibilities were on the table if if
you had all the Hope in the world again
at that age and the reality is one thing
you should take away from this is should
always have that 21y old mindset you
should always have the belief that the
my whole world is in front of me that my
best days are ahead of me that anything
is possible and that I can reinvent
myself right now um I could today on the
spot reinvent myself and to decide I'm a
different guy now I do a different thing
I do things a different way that old guy
he's gone he's the old me and so I think
the first thing to do is to Free
Yourself of the time constraint uh the
age constraint which only adds pressure
and doubt and anxiety to the equation
which none of that helps you be
successful I remember when I was 29
years old and I had this like ex
existential crisis cuz I was like Oh I
thought I was going to be Forbes 30
under 30 and I thought I'd be you know
have a million dollars in my bank
account by now and I didn't have any of
those things and then I was like all
right well guess that didn't happen
moving on and I just continued on and by
30 all of a sudden I sold my company and
had a whole bunch of breakthroughs and a
big part of that was just getting the
weight off my shoulders of feeling like
I'm behind or playing catchup instead I
wanted to be playing offense and so my
question my answer to this question is
comes from a place of offense so let's
take the age out let's think of it like
it's karate or white belt again if we
started as a white belt and we want to
make our way up to a black belt in the
game of success what would we do
so let's break this down into smaller
chunks um I the best metaphor I have or
our best framework I've heard for my
career was that everybody goes through
three phases in their career and the
three phases are number one
learn earn and Legacy so this learn earn
Legacy framework that your career will
go into those chapter the beginning of
your career is generally the learn
period is when you got internships or
you're just starting your first business
you're making a bunch of mistakes um or
you go work at a bigger company just to
see what it's like and you're getting
you know you're getting your experience
that's the learn phase of your career
what's most important in the learn phase
of your career is what you optimize for
so one job offers you an extra $15,000
the other job offers you $155,000 less
which job should you take most people
take the one that pays them the extra
15K a year which is like 9k after taxes
or something like that and and even
though the other job would have been a
far better learning experience for them
that they were going to get way more
hands-on experience working with way
smarter people on more interesting
projects which in the long run would
have paid off in a much bigger way so
why is it important to know you're in
the learn phase because you know what to
prioritize your key kpi is how much
learning per month am I doing how much
am I growing per month as a person I'm
building me as a product right now
that's the learn phase earn phase is now
I've bu built myself as a product I have
the skills I know what to do I
understand the market and I can actually
go and I can reap what I've seed so I
can actually extract some value now I
have cash in the bank which lets me get
to the ultimate point of Financial
Freedom where your money works for money
and you work for you that's where your
Investments generate enough income you
don't need to be doing any job so that
way you can just work on whatever you're
most interested in whatever you're
passionate about whatever you love and
so the earn phase comes next and then
there's a legacy phase which is where
you see a lot of people get to when they
you know they want to go to Mars and
then they want to uh you know buy this
newspaper company to keep you know or
start a foundation or go back and teach
at their college or whatever it is
legacy is how you give back it's how you
remembered for doing something that's
beyond yourself contributing and I think
this framework is a good framework for a
career and I think I think it is the
Natural Evolution of a successful career
that's the first first thing I would
keep in mind so those first 10 years and
I say 10 years 10 years sounds like a
long time but um you know what's the
phrase like we overestimate what we can
do in a year and we underestimate what
we can do in 10 so true um the first 10
years you are in the learn phase you are
actually just uh dabbling so we are told
that we should um stick to it be
determined do blah blah blah that's the
wrong advice uh it's the same bad advice
that gets you when you're 18 19 years
old to declare your major um I even love
that they call it declare like I'm going
to be like yeah you know chemistry right
like you know what are we do based on
what based on what experience I'm a bio
and chemistry major I knew nothing about
any of those I didn't even know what
jobs they create but at 18 years old I'm
supposed to declare my major or fall
behind silly and so we don't want to
fall into the silly traps and pressures
that people pigeon hole you into so what
are you going to do for your for your
major what are you going to do for your
career um what you know what what field
are you in the answer is I'm dating
around right just like we date before we
get married you want to do the same
thing with your career so you're going
to be dabbling so you should be
expecting to I don't know every 18
months
turn over and reinvent yourself and hop
into a new situation to keep challenging
yourself and what you're trying to do is
not you're not trying to change you're
using change to find the thing that you
are uniquely capable of and that's the
next key
lesson I can find this client info have
you heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
so the second thing I would do if I was
starting over again is I would realize
that I'm in the learn phase I would
start dabbling and I would be trying to
identify my Edge this really breaks up
into two categories the first Edge is
one that everybody who's not successful
yet has which is you're small and you're
helpless and what that means is that
people will help you like I can't tell
you how many meetings I got with amazing
people how many opportunities I got how
many times I got to Shadow somebody or
ride along with somebody because I just
told him like Hey I think what you do is
amazing and I don't know the first thing
about it um I I don't know how I can
help you I want to help you someday but
at least I can help you because hey it
always feels good to give back right to
help somebody out I'm giving you that
opportunity can I just can I just figure
learn this with you will you will you
show me how this works and um being
small and helpless is a absolute Edge
that most people who are unsuccessful
try to hide they're embarrassed that
they're not successful they're
embarrassed that they're starting at the
beginning and because of that they throw
away one of their best edges which is
that people want to help people who are
at the who are beginners and so um
Embrace that you're a beginner that is
part of your Edge the next thing is you
got time you're not busy so for me there
are so many opportunities I don't do
because I have a $5,000 an hour time
budget so if something's going to cost
me an hour it needs to be worth at least
$5,000 but when I was younger I would
have done I did Psych studies I would go
take a pill or go you know try to read
from this card for $7 an hour right my
hourly rate was much lower back then and
so I was was willing to do a whole bunch
of things that other people wouldn't do
because I'm not busy my calendar is
clear that's a huge Advantage you have
that's another part of your Edge Another
Part Of Your Edge you have nothing to
lose and by the way a lot of this is
mindset because the actions you take are
Downstream of your mindset right like
the actions you take which is what
people want they want the answer what
I'm giving you is a way for you to
always get the answer so you don't need
to watch a video like this you can be
the guy who makes videos like this and
how do you do that you figure out the
mind first so that then the actions come
quite naturally so let me finish the
mindset section then I'll tell you the
actions so the mindset the next part of
the mindset that matters is you have
nothing to lose so just like you're
small and you're helpless just like you
got a clear calendar and nothing to do
you also got nothing to lose you're
already lost you got nothing you're
starting at rock bottom but that's a
pretty solid foundation and what you
want to do with that Foundation is take
more risks than somebody who has
something to lose for me now if I go do
something I have my reputation people
can see me fail I have to do some things
of a certain caliber and that means me I
might be overlooking some Hidden Gem
type of opportunities um you know I
don't go to conferences I don't go to
certain meetings but you should if
you're in that Boat Boat where you have
nothing to lose because you got
everything to gain um the last thing is
you now need to find your personal Edge
so those first ones are the the common
edges of losers right the losers Edge
and losers have those edges and you
should embrace the losers Edge because
the losers Edge is what helps you become
a winner now you need to find your
personal Edge your personal Edge is
going to be the thing that comes
naturally to you it comes easy to you
maybe you're funny maybe you don't mind
grinding things out when everybody else
gets fatigued maybe you're maybe you
have an eye you have really good taste
and and you know even though you're not
a great designer or product Builder
today you can identify great design and
product building and understand it and
taste is a it could be part of your
personal Edge my friend Chris Williamson
told me this today on a call he goes um
yeah you're like a bear riding a
unicycle I go what he goes um you know a
bear that's cool but not all together
that special a unicycle that's cool but
not not not that special AAR writing a
unicycle that's amazing and so
AAR writing a unicycle is a way to think
about finding that unique combination of
things that makes you you so for some
people it might be that they are a
really talented programmer but they also
love to study anatomy or biology and
they should actually go into that field
the crossover of computer science and
biology for some people it's that
they're just really good with they're a
really good people person and that's
cool but now how do you pair that with
um you know you're you're willing to
work twice as hard as the average person
or you love sports or whatever it is you
try to find an overlap of two or three
things that are true about you that
create a unique combination for me for
example I'm a successful business guy
but I'm not the most successful business
guy right there's people who are worth
hundreds of million dollars I'm not um
but I'm more successful than 98% of
people on the business
side but then I'm also kind of
entertaining and funny I'm good at
talking and there's a lot of better
talkers than me but they're not that
successful on business side there's a
lot of Better Business people than me
but they're kind of boring when they
talk and so my overlap is some
combination of I love you know creating
content I love being curious about
things and turning into content I'm good
at talking and I'm successful that
became my first million a podcast that
really nobody else could host it was
unique to me it was my bear on my
unicycle and um I only found that when I
started following my personal Edge and
so you want to find your personal Edge
and if you don't have one today don't
worry that's okay you're again you're a
blank slate ask your friends what are
some things about me that are true where
am I more above normal people or more
than normal people when it comes to some
area of my life maybe other people can
see it for you or maybe you say look
it's my opportunity to develop that I'm
going to become a great writer by
practicing I'm going to become a great
salesperson by practicing and that'll be
one of my things so you want to create
your personal Edge all right so you've
decided you're in the learn phase you're
dabbling
you're discovering your personal Edge
all right that all comes together and
what happens the scoreboard still says
zero because the scoreboard is this
lagging indicator of how many companies
you've sold how many millions of dollars
you have in the bank um but you are
building up you are not actually at zero
you have made a ton of progress but
there's still one more unlock that you
have to do and that's picking the right
project so what projects would I pick if
I were in this category there's a a
general question I'll I'll I'll give you
some like common questions fork in the
roads that people come to so a fork in
the road I often get is should I start
my own company or should I um should I
join an existing company and get
experience that way and smart people
will tell you both things right
generally people just say the thing that
they did and they say that's the best
way to do things um so you know I think
the real takeaway is that either way
works which one should you choose well
again when you're optimizing for
learning there's a really specific thing
you're actually trying to do you are
trying to get around the smartest and
most ambitious people you can doing the
that also want to do the thing that you
want to do it doesn't matter if that's
you're a musician and you want to uh
then you should be hanging out with
other musicians that are trying to make
it um I have friends that are big
ticktockers or viners or YouTubers they
all moved to LA they all moved into
houses together or on the same street as
each other and they hung out with other
people who were super driven at the same
thing that they wanted to do it's why I
moved to Silicon Valley and that's one
thing I would do again I would pick up
and move to a place where I could find
other people that are just like me
chasing the same dream as me because
that is contagious and you'll be sharing
information so you won't just be
learning your lessons you'll be learning
from the other people around you and
that it will become normal to see people
succeed at doing this it's very um
underrated how important that is to see
other people just like you that you know
are not so much more special than you
succeeding at the thing you want to do
it's what will keep you going even when
times get tough and so that's the first
thing you're trying to do you're
actually trying to pick either the
company or the job that is going to get
you around the smartest most ambitious
people that want to do the same thing as
you want to do for me that was starting
a startup and moving to Silicon Valley
for you that might be joining whatever
this generation's Google is um you know
and and getting around really smart
people that have all flocked to this
thing right like open AI or one of the
one of these companies where a it's a
talent magnet for young ambitious um
motivated people the next thing you need
to do you got to pick the opportunity
whether it's a job or your company or
starting a company that will let you do
actual work versus being an observer On
The Fringe so unfortunately for most
people they go take a job at some
prestigious company and they think ah
I'm getting the experience because of
course working at Facebook in 2024 is
like you know that's I'm getting
experience but their employee number
42,000 Sitting On The Fringe not even
knowing what's actually going on inside
Facebook not getting any access to the
real problems and so whichever path you
choose for me I chose the path of
starting a company and that's the one I
would do again but if you choose even if
you choose joining a company here's your
criteria you have to be working on the
A+ problem every company has the A+
problem at any given time sometimes the
A+ problem is we're getting sued and we
need to deal with this sometimes the a
problem a problem is our growth stopped
and we have no idea why and we got to
get this thing back growing again
sometimes it's we're growing so fast we
can't even keep up with operations hey
can somebody go move to Atlanta and spin
up our Atlanta office cuz we need uh we
need more people in Atlanta
right like I know people that were early
at Uber this was what was going on Uber
was working they couldn't even keep up
with demand and people who made millions
of dollars and became really smart at
Uber were people who were like yeah I'll
go move to Kansas City I'll I'll boot up
Kansas City as a market and they're like
do you have any experience with Kansas
City they're like hell no couldn't even
find it on a map didn't matter they were
willing to go work on the A+ problem
I'll give you a personal example when I
when we got acquired by twitch um they
were like your job is they bought our
orts platform and they were like you're
now the director of Esports Sports okay
cool supposed to work on this orts thing
and my friend said something to me that
my co-founder Fon he said something to
me that stuck with me he goes he was he
was looking at the overall company
dashboard and he's like they're making
some I can't say the number it's not I'm
not allowed to but some huge number
starts with a b and ends with a illion
um in revenue and so they were like he
was like don't you think that when we're
here you know I don't know how long
we're going to be here our vesting date
is is a year from now like don't you
think we should work on something that
at least moves the needle 5% like the
way he said it was wouldn't you feel
like a if we worked here for a
year and we didn't even make a 5% swing
in the company and I was like I would
feel like a if that happened you
know I don't now that you say that I
can't go back to just working he's like
do you think the thing we're doing right
now can swing it by 5 per. I was like
hell no you know like this is that
that's not what this is going to do this
is going to do these other things but
it's not going to do that and so we
basically went on strike from day one
and we were like we're just not going to
do work until we figure out what is the
A+ problem what is the thing that
actually matters in this company and
we're just not going to busy ourselves
until we find that and luckily had a big
company knows nobody knows what the hell
you're doing anyway so the first two
weeks I was just walking around asking
people questions trying to figure out
what actually matters here and I found a
project that was like actually a big
project and we pitched it to the CEO and
we're like hey this is a big problem do
you have anyone who's solving this and
he's like no it's like cool I'm free
he's like you're free I thought you're
supposed to be working on the thing I'm
like nah but this is bigger right and
he's like yeah it is bigger and so we he
created a special team and we ran it to
do that thing and we actually made a big
impact um this happened again I remember
when I was at twitch and the top
streamer on Twitch was this guy named
ninja he got sponsored by Red Bull and
he was like the star he was on TV all
the time and fortnite was in it tday and
ninja was the guy and then Microsoft
came and paid ninja like $20 million to
leave twitch and go over there and we
lost our our biggest streamer overnight
it's like if you know the warriors uh
you know if somebody came and took Steph
Curry off the Warriors just paid him and
he left it's like oh and it was an
oh moment I said well that's
probably the A+ problem right now so
what did I do I dropped everything I was
doing and I started working on that
nobody had told me even what to work on
but I wrote a memo I said hey it looks
like he left here's some data analysis
on how big of a problem that is or how
little of a problem that is here's my
strategy recommendation on what we
should do and I just send it to the CEO
right when in doubt put a letter in the
CEO's mailbox and he's like this is
great here joining he put me in three
group chats right away which were like
the team the ex teams that were working
on that and he's like hey you know
Sean's in on this and they're like why
he doesn't he's supposed to be doing
this other thing it's like he has good
he has good thoughts on this and so
there's a way to work on the A+ problem
even if you're in a big company or if
you're an entrepreneur by definition you
should always be working on the A+
problem it's forced and so I learned
that skill because I first started my
own companies and I knew you just got to
always be working on the one big thing
what's the one A+ problem right now so
that's the second principle you have to
do during this early phase so what would
I actually do I would be be whether I
start my own company or Join one I would
be finding a way to work on the A+
problem at all times the last one is I'm
creating luck I'm creating a landing
area for luck and I want Lady Luck to
come when she's flying by to see the
surface area on my back and say that
looks like a good spot to set up camp
for the night and how do you do that
well I heard this great thing I've said
it a couple times in the podcast but you
know what great things are worth
repeating there are four levels of luck
you got to be aware of them and then
actually manufacture them so luck is not
something that happens to you it is
something that you can create and
increase the odds of happening in your
life the first level of luck is just
blind luck that's the one where you
didn't do you just got struck by
lightning all right fair enough nothing
really really you could do for that
first level of luck except for
appreciate it when it does happen
sometimes things truly do fall in your
lap but that's rare second level of luck
is you're taking a bunch of action
you're just doing a bunch of and
then good things happen to you and this
is fortune favors the bold and so you
should be looking at how do I I just do
more things show up to more events uh
make some introductions for people uh
you know just publish an analysis of
something on the Internet and maybe
somebody smart will read it and think
hey this guy's awesome I would love to
meet him you know these are the things
you do to create luck content is an
amazing way to create luck so if I was
25 again I would be creating content in
not because I think I could create a big
audience in fact I almost think that
would be a disservice if everybody's now
listening to some 23-year-old
25-year-old who's got no experience no
track record of success like I'm not
trying to present myself as a thought
leader what I would be trying to do is
publishing my thoughts which puts
pressure on me to have good thoughts and
go learn some in order to hopefully
have a small group of people who are
interesting think that I'm interesting
and that increases my surface area for
Lu so I'd be creating content on a
regular basis publishing my thoughts I
think um when my intern came on here the
episode called you know my intern uh my
18-year-old intern became a millionaire
one of the reasons why why is because he
said that he either he wrote it or his
friend wrote an analysis about a stock
why the stock was good and like of
course you're 18 years old what do you
really know about stocks but it forced
him to think why this could be a good
buy and he published it and then someone
interesting followed him because of that
and that became a lunch and then that
guy became his investor and like all
this series of events played out because
he was putting his thoughts out there on
the internet and I think that's just
like a core thing I would be doing on a
regular basis but not to become popular
and not to I always say you don't want
to be well- known you want to be known
well so I would not be trying to be
popular and get the biggest audience
possible I would be trying to put my
original thoughts and most unique
analysis out there so that the right
people find me the people that I want to
be known well by because that's how new
opportunities are going to happen Okay
so let's say I've gone down this path
for me that would be I would start a
company well what company it'd be any
company where I feel like there's a um
you you know a problem and a solution
fit for me now that would be a service
company I didn't do this at the time but
with the benefit of hindsight I would
say cool I would do some basic envelope
math I would say well I want to
have can I have 10 customers paying me
$10,000 a month 10 customers now $10,000
might sound crazy but like for a
business business to spend $10,000 on
things uh but I would say that would be
my Benchmark 10 customers paying me
$10,000 a month that's $100,000 a month
of income which is baller if you
missed that part so if you're doing 100K
a month you're doing 1.2 a year you're
doing the work mostly so it's you know
90% profit margin you hire one or two
schleps to work with you and now you
know you're 85% profit margin you're
making a million dollars a year profit
that would be my goal of what I'm trying
to get to now what type of service would
I would I do well I would work backwards
from what's a service that I think I
could pull off that um doesn't I would
not limit myself to my skills so what I
would do is I would go on upwork or I
would go on Fiverr or I would go I would
look at other agencies that are already
existing I'll try to figure out what is
a agency or Consulting service that
people are willing to pay 10K a month
for on a retainer like on a recurring
basis that either I could do myself or I
could hire people overseas um to do them
right like I'm an investor in Shephard
you can go on Shephard you can say hey
uh I want web developers in ladam that I
pay a th000 you know I pay a th000 to
$2,000 a month and then you could create
a web development agency then you could
go and you know what I would do is I
would go and I would email everybody
every real estate agent in my city very
easy contact information to F I would
say hey um I was on your website it
doesn't look great but um you know hey
look at this example website this other
guy his website's awesome um I make
awesome websites like that if you ever
want to want a website like I'm happy to
to do it for you or hey uh
you know that's probably a lower ticket
item that's probably like you know $500
a month and I'll do that for you and you
get way more people to do it or you go
to a senior living facility and you say
hey guy who runs a senior living a
nursing home uh you know if you've ever
met people who run nursing homes they're
not the best at marketing they're
usually like older people who are in the
hospitality business maybe the real
estate business and you'd say hey um I'd
love to sit down with you because I
think I can help you fill your occupancy
in your senior living facility because I
know that's in occupancy is directly
translates to cha-ching in their ears
and so occupancy rate goes up means more
beds booked means more money for them
and I would say if I could bring you one
new occupant per month um what would you
be willing to pay me they say well well
we make $6,000 a month off each person
so I would pay you their first month
rent i' pay you six grand for every
person you could bring in you say
fantastic so I just got to get you two
people a month and I'm making 10 over 10
grand a month off this one facility and
then I would figure out how to create
content or do cold calling or do lead
gen or throw events or go to the
hospitals and partner with people and
figure out hey hospital when you kick
people out when they're still old and
sick but you don't keep them anymore
where do they go and they're like oh we
just all send them to this one facility
and I'm and I would say hey how can I
get you to send me those leads because
um we have a great facility to take care
of those people and so I would I would
go find an industry that needs help
getting customers and I would help them
get customers either through their
website through their Facebook ad
they're marketing whatever and I don't
need to be an expert because you know
what's it to to a blind man the one man
is king that's what I would go look for
I would go look for the blind man I
would go look for someone who's running
a senior living facility is probably
terrible at marketing probably doesn't
know how to run a Google ad and so if I
just sit here for eight hours on YouTube
I'm pretty sure I can become the
smartest Google ad person in their life
and that's what I would do and so I
would try to figure out a way to do this
product productized agency and try to
get to that 100K a month uh bar and I'd
be okay at the first month getting to
1,000 a month 4,000 a month 10,000 a
month uh but slowly but surely be be
trying to build up to that to that level
and the math I said earlier about 10
customers paying you 10K it doesn't
matter whether it's 10 paying 10 or it's
20 paying five or it's 30 paying three I
could do this all day by the way um you
are just trying to do math to get figure
out how do you get to $100,000 uh
dollars a month oh okay I need to be
able to service let's say 25 customers
do I think I can find 25 humans on Earth
that are willing to pay me 4 grand month
to help them get more customers yes
right like that's what I would do um and
then by the way I would take that agency
and as soon as I get it to 100K a month
I would go try to sell it because I'm
doing let's say 800 to 900k a year
profit and I would go try to sell that
for four times profit and I'd have $4
million that's what I would try to do um
all right so now let's pretend I'm
somewhere in the middle of that process
and I get a little bit of money here's a
common mistake people make get a little
bit of money you get 10 20 grand you've
been listening to podcasts from Schmucks
like me and you're like oh I think I
should be investing um Angel Investing
S&P 500 Bond what's a bond and you start
trying to come up with some like
Financial
strategy complete waste of time um you
don't want to be making 8% on $80,000 a
year it honestly doesn't matter if your
goals are to be a multi-millionaire
successful person who's going to do big
things in their life of course if to you
$8,000 is like the jackpot then do that
but most people listen to this podcast
that is titled my first million are not
going to be happy at that level they're
trying to be in you know the seven
figure eight figure nine figure club and
so how do you get there you get there by
not wasting time and energy on the wrong
things the wrong thing would be you have
a very small principal amount of money
and you're going try to earn a you're
going try to beat the market and earn a
12% or 15% annual return on $42,000 it
just simply doesn't matter so the advice
the good advice you'll hear here about
this is well um you should invest in
yourself and so most people hear that
they're like yeah you're right I should
invest in myself and then they're like
where do I put the money where the
does the money go how do you invest in
yourself what do you do um most have no
idea what you actually do and so here's
what to me investing in yourself means
let's break it into three categories
category one buying back your time so
the first investment you want to make in
yourself is to get your creative energy
back so when you're doing life you're
unfortunately forced to do a bunch of
Life and life sucks
away your creative forces uh life
is running an errand doing a
return having to go um you know take the
bus to the airport because you can't
afford an Uber ride whatever so the very
first thing you're going to do is you're
going to identify any area of your life
where you are leaking Creative Energy
spending time on something that you a
don't enjoy and B doesn't make you money
you're going to buy that back so you're
going to be a 24y old with a housekeeper
and people people are going to think
you're spoiled you're going to be the
27-year-old who doesn't return the
blender that doesn't work because it's
not worth your time to go to the store
and drop it off um you are going to buy
back your time you're going to hire an
assistant overseas for $800 a month
using Shephard promo code Sean in order
to um buy back your time and not have to
deal with tedious back and forths of
scheduling or whatever it is um if
you're doing a product eyes service
you're going to hire a designer so that
you don't have to do the design work
anymore so you're going to buy back your
time that's category one of how you
actually literally invest in yourself um
category two how do you invest in
yourself you invest in the knowledge as
Ty Lopez likes to say and the knowledge
is of course books you give yourself an
unlimited book budget but you go beyond
that you're going to buy your way into a
um you know any conference or group or
member members Club where you know that
people who are where you want to be hang
out and you're going to get around them
more often because proximity Is Power
and the more time you spend around
people who are the way you want to be
the more you will automatically through
osmosis become like them um the third
one is so you you've bought back your
time you've bought your way in to being
around proximity around other people
that you want sometimes that's moving to
a better location it's conferences it's
membership clubs it's masterminds
whatever three is invest in yourself uh
by leaving money on the
table oh what is he talking about
that sounds smart that's some that's
some Uno reverse card right
what how do you invest in yourself by
leaving money on the table you invest in
yourself by saying no to clients that
are going to waste your time you invest
in yourself by taking a lower paying job
with a badass person right let's say I
take 25k less to go work for a badass
person which by the way I did um I took
a multi-million dollar pay cut in our
acquisition because in one I was going
to get to work with the CEO and in the
other I was going to be three layer
below the CEO and so I just decided I'd
rather be around smarter people um and
you know optimize for that and so I
believe that what you should do is you
should take pay cuts to put yourself in
great opportunities around amazing
people or working with amazing people um
maybe you take a little less Equity
maybe you take a little bit less salary
uh in order to be with the right people
and so that's that's the last way you
invest in yourself because you say yeah
I left that 25k on the table but I also
invested that in being in a better
opportunity for myself which is going to
lead to good things down the road all
right let's move to the next next
questions we got a couple left here so
this idea of do I try to make a bunch of
money first or do I do something Mission
oriented um which is the Justin May's
quote um first get your nut then do
something Noble um I believe this is
true this is the life version of put
your oxygen mask on you before you put
it on your kids like like you see here
on an airplane so I think there is a
certain threshold of success which is
youve built skills you know how to build
you know how to sell it right you
know how to figure out a product and you
know how to Market it so you got to
build that core skill set it doesn't
really matter whether you're selling you
know um you know these cans or you're
selling uh lifechanging you know
Pharmaceuticals it's kind of the same
thing you need to build a core skill set
first don't don't worry about the
product in that meantime the second
thing is going to be um you need enough
money enough Runway to chase a noble
Mission so like if you go try to chase a
noble Mission but you don't know where
the rent comes from every month um you
were going to lower your odds of success
pretty dramatically just because you
didn't give yourself enough Runway to go
do something bold and audacious and
ambitious of course don't fall into the
Trap of perpetually waiting the next
year maybe next year I'll have enough
time money experience to go do the thing
I really want to do I believe you should
always go do the thing you really want
to do
I don't think the thing you really want
to do has to be a noble world changing
Mission um especially at the beginning
and so I wouldn't put that pressure on
myself so to summarize my answer on what
I would do if I was young broke starting
from scratch again in
2024 I would break my career up into
three phases the learn earn Legacy I
would um spend my learn phase dabbling
trying to find the thing that I really
love to do that I am uniquely good at so
it's that zone of Genius the thing the
market wants that you're good at that
you enjoy doing uh the bear on the
unicycle and you you try to find that
thing I would take advantages of my
edges I would identify my Edge and I
would take advantage of the edges of
losers um during that time I would
optimize around getting around the
smartest and most ambitious people I can
find I would do the actual work the A+
problem I would create luck I would not
worry about investing I would only
invest in myself along the way and that
is as I get a phone call that is my
answer of what I would do if I was
starting over from
[Music]
scratch um yeah so I guess I just start
a marketing
agency